hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in question two
of premise hakuna of the Summa theologia
Thomas Aquinas is considering what could
possibly be happiness what are the
candidates for genuine and full human
happiness and in articles 2 through 4
after having considered wealth in quite
an article one he's going to consider
three other things they're kind of
closely related that human beings often
mistakenly think happiness too
consistent often because of the lack
they say oh if I could just have this
then my life would be fulfilled and I
would be particularly happy and those
three things are honours on or ebooks
write in on or ebooks
fame or glory nowadays we might actually
say celebrity and power or authority
positions being able to control being
able to tell other people what to do and
so all of these you notice have to do
with the social world and how it is that
we human beings interact with each other
so you know being respected by other
people having them tell us what what
great you know persons we are getting
lots of you
thumbs up or likes or something like
that in social media fame glory
celebrity people you know talking about
as having a reputation and then being
able to determine how things go within
the social world because you are you
know in a higher part of the status
hierarchy and you're able to tell people
what to do so these are things that
people do in fact desire they do strive
for them and they value them and why is
it the case well if we look at the
objections in the text you know Thomas
is putting forth arguments that other
people would say he says that a
happiness is the reward of virtue but
honor more than anything else seems to
be that by which virtue is rewarded so
it's a sign that we've made it if we get
honor he also notes that in a way being
honored is like being like God or people
he says of great excellence that seems
to be especially happiness which is the
perfect good and so honor would
presumably make us like that if we go
down to fame and glory you know why
people would think that's the case
there's another similar thing he says
happiness seems to consist in that which
is paid to the saints for the trials
they've undergone in the world but this
is glory Software's if we're like
thinking about the Saints probably not
what most people thinking about
reputation fame or glory are thinking
about but if we were then that would be
kind of similar to that that discussion
in honor but there's there's other cases
he says here's another one happiness is
the most enduring good this seems to be
fame or glory why why would that be the
case because by this man attained to
eternity after a fashion
so boethius says in the consolation you
seem to be get into yourselves eternity
when you think of your fame in future
time now of course boëthius is saying
that in order to knock it down and so is
thomas but there are a lot of people who
miss
taken Li think that fame glory
reputation celebrity is going to last
forever and in some respects there's
nothing sadder than seeing somebody who
you know expects everyone to know who
they are and they are no longer somebody
when we get to power now we're in a
somewhat different realm and here in
addition to these motifs that we've
already had before there's some other
things that are coming up right he says
that happiness would seem to consistent
power why all things desire to become
like to God men who are in power seem on
account of the similarity if I were to
be most like God so happiness with
consistent power that's similar to the
honor thing or the fame or glory but
Aquinas says this is an argument that he
gives without bringing anybody else in
happiness is the perfect good the
highest perfection for a human being is
to be able to rule others which belongs
to those who are in power so a lot of
people do see things this way they
orient their life around bossing other
people around or getting to be the
person behind the scenes who decides you
know all of the things that then the
figureheads the people are the fame and
glory they end up having to enact right
a third thing that he says is that since
happiness is supremely desirable it's
contrary to that which before all is to
be shunned what is that
more than anything else Thomas says
human beings shun servitude they don't
want other people to tell them what to
do they they want freedom in a certain
sense to be able to determine for
themselves and not have somebody else
telling them how they have to behave or
when they have to do things so by that
argument power would indeed be the
highest good now Thomas is going to
point out one other thing in this as
well people are willing to sacrifice
other things that might be considered
happiness like wealth or pleasure for
these things what's the evidence for it
people do in fact behave that way right
the the person who puts in 80-hour weeks
you know for for months and months on
end so that they can win the prize or be
you know employee of the month or
whatever it is or getting to get to be
in charge because of you know the way
that our meritocracy works or doesn't
work that would be in an instance of
that Thomas points out for general
problems with all of these and it's good
to concentrate on those and we can come
back to some of the more specific
problems with other ones so the first
general problem is if it really was the
greatest good then you wouldn't find it
in bad or evil people all right he says
since happiness is the human being
supreme good it's incompatible with any
evil all of these things can be found in
both good and in evil people so that by
itself is not a particularly strong an
argument but when you put it together
with the others you can see where he's
going with this a second thing that's
probably more on point if something's
going to be happiness then it should be
complete all right and he says that
people who have these things power Fame
honor they they still lack other goods
when they have them they may not
actually have that Pleasant of a life or
their pleasure consist just an
exercising power they could be lacking
in health
they could be lacking in all sorts of
other things these are not complete as
many people come to realize once they do
have the opportunity to possess and
enjoy them you know a third one that's
kind of the flip side of this is that
happiness if it truly is complete
happiness it should render us unable it
should render us you know free from
evils he says since happiness is the
perfect good no
people can accrue to anyone they're from
but not only can we suffer evil evil can
come to us from these things he uses the
example of wealth he says sometimes
riches are kept of the herd of the owner
and this you know is a sign that wealth
is not happiness but we could think
about honor right
you get honored for something and then
precisely because you were honored for
that thing you're gonna be held in
dishonor later same thing can happen
with power same thing can happen with
fame or glory oh man they were so you
know 1999 right people said in 2000 I'm
not interested in that celebrity anymore
well that's that's that's a problem
right and you know particularly if you
consider Fame or celebrity there's all
sorts of problems that can arise out of
that one of them is that you can't
actually figure out who your real
friends are and who is just you know
either try to take advantage of you or
infatuated by your celebrity right and
we could say similar things with power
and these are real signs that it's not
happiness itself finally the fourth
point that Thomas makes is that these
are goods of fortune that is they are
due to external causes you might say
well why is that a problem
you know couldn't you just be like happy
because you were lucky and you wound up
with the right sorts of things Thomas
says human beings are a deigned to
happiness through principles that are in
them because we're ordained thereto
naturally so there would have to be
something developing within us this is
sort of in the background of what Thomas
is saying that would allow us to enjoy
genuine happiness genuine happiness
would not just be a function of what we
happen to be lucky in getting it would
be a matter of the development of
ourselves as human beings so those are
problems with these three in particular
there are some other specific issues
that he
points out as well you know one of the
things is that you know we're really not
like God when it comes to our enjoyment
of these things and you know in the case
of power it's a very good thing for a
person to make good use of power and
ruling it's also a bad thing if they
make a bad use of it and you know
talking about fame or glory and also
talking about honors he says well who
are you getting that from
does it matter who is giving you the
homage or respect do you want it from
everybody or do you want it from the
people who you value whose opinions you
think matter because they're not stupid
or they have something to contribute or
they themselves have excelled I'll give
you just one prime example you know I
could make some you know music videos
and put them on YouTube and do some
outrageous things while I'm playing my
bass guitar or my banjo I'm not very
good at either and I could you know if I
if I did the right keywords and you know
did the right kind of outrageous
behavior I might get you know millions
and millions of views and people would
be like yeah put him on a talk show you
know bring him in I would still suck as
a musician right and if I want to be
honored you know if I want to win some
award or something I don't want it to
come from a bunch of people I don't
actually know or care about I would want
to be valued by people who actually work
within the field you know so you know
let's switch gears let's say it's about
philosophy right if I'm gonna be honored
for my work in philosophy I don't just
want it to be a bunch of random people
or you know some some latest website
trying to you know make a name for
itself in creating lists I want people
who I actually value to say yeah you're
doing good work man I like what you're
doing that would actually be meaningful
to me and that's because you know those
are the people who actually do matter in
terms of these measures but even if I
don't get that I can still be happy
these are not
what happiness consists in according to
Thomas Aquinas
you